from 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea to the
tales of the mythical Kraken the giant
squid has long loomed large in the
popular imagination but for actual
science the creature has eluded us we
only really know about it from specimens
that have washed ashore or even caught
in Nets until now for the second time
ever and for the first time in US waters
researchers have captured a giant squid
on camera so how do they do it and what
does this mean for our understanding of
this mysterious creature to find out we
are speaking to one of the expedition's
leaders dr. Edith Witter she's also the
one responsible for developing the
technology that made this all possible
so this is obviously a very elusive
creature as one if you could walk us
through what exactly science does know
so far about this animal that has been
very difficult to actually spot in the
wild so for the longest time what we
knew about giant squid was based on the
dead specimens that floated to the
surface but seeing one in its natural
habitat became what was called the holy
grail of natural history cinematography
and I have been saying for some time
that I think we need to try exploring
the deep ocean in a different way the
primary way we know about life in the
ocean is we drag Nets behind ships and I
defy you to name any other branch of
science that still depends on hundreds
of year old technology it's an axiom
among marine scientists that Nets only
capture the slow the stupid and the
greedy and so how much are we missing
and if we go down with submersibles and
remote operated vehicles they have
really bright lights and sometimes very
noisy thrusters and any sensible animal
is going to get out of the way and so I
wanted a different way to explore and
started trying to develop a camera
system that could see without being seen
and so I developed this optical lure
that we call the electronic jellyfish or
a jelly that imitates certain
bioluminescent displays that I thought
might be attractive to large predators
and sure enough it was can you tell us
more about the
a jelly what kind of organism is it
mimicking and how is it doing so it's a
bunch of blue LEDs that are embedded in
epoxy and they're imitating the display
of a jellyfish that when it is caught in
the clutches of a predator it produces
this pinwheel of light that is meant as
a scream for help
and it's called a bioluminescent burglar
larva because it functions very much
like the burglar alarm on your car the
blaring horn and flashing lights are
meant to attract attention hopefully of
the police and cause the burglar to run
away because it doesn't want to get
caught well the same thing is true for a
lot of animals in the ocean that can
make light if they're caught in the
clutches are predator they may use every
light organ they've got in the flashiest
way possible pun intended to attract the
attention of a larger predator how do we
now understand the creature better than
we used to it's very clear that this is
an active visual predator you see this
giant squid surfing along beside the
camera and the electronic jellyfish it's
tracking exactly what the camera is
doing so it's you know it's clearly a
visual predator it watches it for a
while and then comes in for the attack
obviously this would be an exciting
discovery somewhat memorable what was it
like out there on the high seas there's
actually probably the most unusual day
at sea I've ever had I was doing this
project in collaboration with Nathan
Robinson the video is collected over 24
to 30 hour period by the camera system
and we don't know what we've got until
we collect the camera and download it it
takes many hours to download the data
and then many more hours to go through
it and Nate was going through it in the
lab she came in and he didn't even say
anything his eyes were just about
popping out of his head I knew it was
something important and I came running
into the lab and there it was this giant
squid coming out of the bloom I'm
attacking the e-jelly and it was you
know it was incredible and then others
from around the ship came running around
to see it and we wanted to confirm
before we shared it with the world that
it really was
squit and so we wanted to connect with
the Smithsonian but the internet was
down because we were in the middle of
the squall and as we were still all
around the computer watching this loop
over and over again the ship got hit by
lightning which has never happened to me
in all my years of going to see ran out
under the fantail and there was this
plume of yellow and brown smoke and bits
of antenna on the deck it had to hit the
antenna on the ship
we all thought at the moment at the same
moment oh my god what about the computer
because we hadn't backed up the video
yet we've just gotten it and what a
disaster that would have been but we ran
in and our laptop that this was on was
okay some of the other computers
actually did get zapped and then even as
we were still kind of processing all of
this still didn't have internet the
captain comes down and tells us that
there's a waterspout forming off of our
port bow and so it really felt like
Poseidon was trying to protect his
secrets but eventually we did get the
internet back up and we were able to
send the video to Mike Vecchio at the
Smithsonian and he was able to confirm
that yes in all likelihood as much as he
was willing to put his reputation on the
line it was a giant squid it was
probably a juvenile with the mantle and
the arms it was probably about 12 feet
long if the tentacles were fully
extended it would be even longer than
that with a full adult as far as we know
they can get as tall as a four-story
building it sounds like a scene out of
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea you've got
a giant cephalopod and angry seas all
coming together and some high drama yeah
I think Jules Verne would have approved
so up until this point why has it been
that we haven't really seen much of
these giant squid especially alive out
in the wild we've actually explored very
little of what is the largest habitat on
the planet the open ocean mostly we know
about what lives there by dragging nets
but visits with submersibles and remote
operated vehicles are few and far
between and when you think in terms of
the volume that we're talking about this
is an enormous
more than 99.9% of the biosphere the
living space on the planet is in the
water and and we've just barely barely
glimpsed the life down there and maybe a
creature like the giant squid this
science fiction creature which is a head
with arms and tentacles whipping out of
it and a beak that can rip flesh and
eyes the size of a dinner plate and
three hearts that can pump blue blood I
mean it doesn't get any better than that
and if that would excite the public's
interest which it seems to have done
then that's awesome thank you for
talking with us today we appreciate it
I was glad to do it
[Music]